I'm desperately trying to pass along uh
my thoughts to help you to understand
how the world order is changing um and
it's changing in three very important
ways it's changing financially and
economically in important ways that you
could see it's changing because of the
great internal conflict that's happening
and it's also changing because of the
external conflict these three things are
coming together to create a perfect
storm of sorts and I want to help you
understand that by passing it along I'm
doing that in um a couple of ways I've
written a book principles for dealing
with the changing world order I have
done a free animated video called The
Changing World Order I'm on these social
posts in the way that we're now
interacting if you take your questions
and you post them in the comments I'm
going to take the best questions and I'm
going to answer them I'll answer them
here and I'm going to answer them across
my social media so everyone could
benefit so it's there for you if you
want it um and if you don't want it it's
okay I'm at a stage in my life 74 years
old and where I feel compelled to pass
that along to you so it's there for you
to take your leave